there's quite a lot of good news about
covered 19 recently but some people have
been pointing towards quite a scary
statistic certainly scary
on the surface and it comes in this
table from public health england looking
at who's got the delta variants and
what's happened to them later on
and i'll just circle it you can see it
there look of those who've received two
doses of the vaccination 224
died in fact actually if you look across
those who have been vaccinated one or
two dose
the majority of those deaths were people
who were vaccinated which raised us a
question are the vaccines
working what's going wrong here well
it's worth just bearing in mind
two things here because actually these
numbers aren't quite as scary as they
look at first the first thing
is that even though these vaccines
should reduce the risk
of death they don't eliminate it now
these bars here show you your mortality
risk so the risk of getting the disease
and dying by age group from youngest to
oldest and you can see obviously the
oldest
that 90 year old group is very high
indeed i'll just put that into a
logarithmic scale so you can see the
bottom end as well
and let's just kind of go through this
so 90 year olds up there pre-vaccination
60 year olds for instance
pre-vaccination
are down there but if we reduce those
bars in line with what those
pharmaceutical companies say they should
be reduced by
that they go down the risk of dying
across the piece goes down but
even so even if they're working
supposedly as they should do
the risk for a 90 year old is still in
line with a 60 year old
pre-vaccination so it's not eliminating
it but it is reducing it
second thing is this just look at how
many people have been vaccinated
of that pool that we're talking about so
these are people who've got delta you
can see that about 85 percent or so
were vaccinated so that's most of your
sample pool and then when you look at
other things like hospitalizations
those blue bars the blue bit of the bar
is bigger than the red bit
but now break it down look at how many
of those people who were vaccinated went
on to hospital it's about 3.5 percent
now look at how much of the red bit so
those who are unvaccinated
were hospitalized 8.4 you see
there's a difference a kind of
difference in likelihood 2.4 times more
hospitalizations per case among those
who are
unvaccinated and yet the sheer number of
those who
are hospitalized having been vaccinated
is higher
similar thing when we look at deaths as
well so the same thing again we start
with total number of cases
then we look at the number of deaths and
then we look at how many deaths
per case and for vaccinated people it's
two percent of those who are
tested positive a delta went on to die
for unvaccinated
it's 5.6 of those uh who got the disease
went on to die so a higher proportion
again
2.8 times more deaths per case and yet
the sheer number of those who have
vaccinated who went on to die was
greater than the number who unvaccinated
just underlines that simple numbers on
their own
don't tell the full story